we can't risk having another villain in
this game wait a second here
did we hear you guys right another
villain escaped through the barrier and
now you're planning on closing it
forever
you have to close career forever and
people hear this what are you guys
hiding we want some answers and by the
way you don't need to worry about
telling the public what's going on the
black and purple sky says it all but are
you really going to let them have it now
keep watching to find out the truth
about the black magic in descendants
three Celia facili a wasn't getting
around when she said that a great evil
was coming for auradon and that it would
have its revenge there's literally an
entire island of villains who want to
see auradon fall so it's really anyone's
game right now
Audrey Ouma Hades doctor facili a heck
even Maleficent the lizard could be in
on it
but not many villains are powerful
enough to SiC dark magic upon auradon
this purple magic is tearing Ordon apart
brick by brick it even destroyed Jane's
adorable birthday cake but just where is
it coming from to get an answer to that
question we've got to look at the stone
cold facts or rather the color of the
black magic it's dark purple and pink
with hints of blue it oddly resembles
mouths hair and the way it's been
changing from purple to midnight blue
but since we doubt mal is behind the
destruction of her very own happily ever
after we're pointing a finger at her
dear old mom or to be more specific
Maleficent scepter
[Music]
by now were sold on Audrey being the one
who steals the Queen's crown and
Maleficent sceptre and we basically see
her casting a spell out of her dorm
window in auradon prep so chances are
she's the one who's unleashing the dark
magic but Maleficent scepter doesn't
glow green for just anybody so there's
got to be more at work here audrey has
been stealing the show for so long that
we almost forgot about Hades and dr.
facili a who both definitely play a
wicked hand in Oregon's destruction so
what if Audrey isn't exactly acting out
of her own accord what if someone is
vicariously living through her and
trying to make himself look innocent
we're talking about you Hades and why
you might be up to no good in the
mystery trailer we see Hades draining
mouths powers and attacking the vks he
looks super angry and is trying to
escape through the barrier
but then for some strange reason we see
him in auradon prep waving his ember in
front of Sleeping Beauty's daughter
although it might look like he's trying
to help her villains have been known to
have ulterior motives so the real
question is why would Mouse dad go from
stealing her powers to healing the one
person who openly hates her it just
doesn't make any sense unless perhaps
Hades is transferring the powers he
stole from mal into Audrey's body this
could explain why the black magics
spreading over Oregon is the exact same
shade as mouths very own powers in The
Descendants novels we find out that
Maleficent sceptre dragon eye has a
curse on it anyone who isn't Maleficent
or mal will fall asleep for 1,000 years
if they touch it so Audrey wouldn't be
able to touch the scepter without taking
a permanent snooze but if Audrey has
mouths magic at her fingertips it might
be enough to stop her from getting kurtz
this could explain why dragon eye starts
glowing a bright green when who we
believe to be Audrey approaches it a
tease might be trying to come off as a
good guide to distract the bee case from
what's really going on
or a dawn under attack
oh my that sounds terrible there are
clear signs of Hades involvement in the
dark magic trailer we catch a glimpse of
a little cottage in the woods being
overtaken by black magics and just
before Jane's birthday cake flashes
across the screen two candlesticks burst
into blue flames
we all know there's only one villain who
can create these bright blue flames and
that's Katie's so he could totally be
involved in turning Audrey into Oregon's
biggest threat every single descendents
3 trailer has ended in a similar fashion
we see a tarot card flash across the
screen telling us what to expect next
and the black magic trailer is no
different except for one little tidbit
we don't see any words printed into the
card it's a blank slate but since we all
know that Audrey is going to steal the
crown and the sceptre fans are convinced
that the person on the card is Audrey
it's clear that Audrey is trying to be
like mal or like maleficent at the very
least and the image on the card paints a
very ugly picture we see Audrey and her
queen of mean outfit looking out at a
heavily destructed landscape since we're
still waiting to see a doctor faciliate
trailer we're thinking this may be the
card he shows Audrey if and when she
pays him a visit what do you guys think
why is Audrey's card linked and who's
behind the mysterious black magic sound
off in the comments give this video a
big thumbs up if you're excited for
descendants 3 and hit that subscribe
button so you never miss another video
thanks for watching the scenes we'll
catch you later
[Music]